we were in Denver I took some mushrooms
on stage did Jacob tell you I was going
to be a little high oh I played a song
midet uh it dawned on me that maybe our
Kelly had missed out on a couple
opportunities so I wrote I wrote a song
for him
one time in my
life I met a
girl we went back to
my
place and then at the end the set I was
like I'm going to close with a song and
I played the same song because I forgot
that I had played
it our Kelly missed out on a couple
[Music]
opportunities I'll land the plane
everybody it's all right totally
okay I just think that he he left a
couple hits out there so I wrote one
for
one time in my life
I met a
girl went back to
my
place
we rolling
around she stopped the
fun she said right to
my face P
me and then the crowd started singing
along and I was like holy sh all
right I'm into
that unless
you just ate as
sparus I was like this song's really
catching on I had no idea but they had
just heard it 5 minutes before but that
was why they were singing
along I want to get
peed on and I got a little St AG right
yeah nothing came out it's hard to pee
when a stranger is staring at you and I
didn't know till after the show he goes
hey you know you repeated that song I
was like what he goes you played that
song twice and then I was like uh right
right
right I was like you're not wondering
why they were singing along yeah dude it
felt so good are you kidding
[Applause]
me that is ridiculous and I said okay
but it's hard to pee on someone
else when you have
got a
full all right that's all I get for that
song uh all right
everybody I had a good time with you
tonight I hope we see you out there that
was quite a mushroom show man I
I I don't know if I was up here for it
feels like 5 minutes or but I at the
clock the clock does not say 5
minutes but I thank you guys for
sticking it out that was
amazing thank
you